after the call to 911 the cops and the
coroner have gone things must be put
back in order even when things will
never ever be the same it's gruesome
work but someone's got to do it when a
life ends in the worst possible way in
the vicinity of Maryland or Washington
DC it's often a cue for Louise Burkhart
to start work louise excels at a job few
want and even fewer could stand to do I
go out to scenes of homicide suicide
decomposed ravines or any kind of
biological incident and clean up and
restore it to the situation that it was
prior to the incident occurring the
first thing we do obviously is we
observe the situation because every
situation is totally different today
we're dealing with a suicide sorry to
meet you like this that's okay keeping
the lady that we're dealing with her
husband committed suicide and he had
three children basically what I'm gonna
do is go in look at everything after I
see exactly what we have to deal with
and we'll go ahead and start working
okay thank you very much
now Louise must grapple with the horrors
that lie beyond the bedroom door she
focuses on the process take it all in
and what I'm gonna do is pull the other
sheets that we can wrap it on that they
must look closely what seems to be a
tiny stain may be masking a hidden mass
of residue what it does is it which
store when it can be large or underneath
than it is from the top surface if we
can't properly clean something obviously
we have to remove it dispose of its
medical waste
sometimes the crew must remove threats
to health other times they try to shield
survivors from even more heartbreak we
take high-powered lights and check and
recheck and recheck to make sure that we
have everything so that when the family
comes in they don't have to deal with
something unexpected we're looking for
if there was any overspray of blood any
tissue teeth um it could be anything
there's times where you found body
actual body parts whether it be a nose
or somebody they shot themselves it's
their eye you have to search everything
in the area to make sure that there
isn't anything left behind Louise has
been cleaning up after death for 11
years it's a profitable business lately
her son Mac has been helping his mom in
the field to support herself and her
children Louise started out working on
contract with the local medical
examiner's office transporting bodies we
started having people ask us when it was
a homicide or a suicide wall could you
clean this up and to be honest with you
I didn't think I could
however I turned around and at one point
I said yeah well I could give it a shot
and we tried it but we still thought it
would just be a little sigh it was a
little sideline kind of thing did not
expect that there was much of a need but
the market for post-mortem cleanup crews
grew with surprising speed the new niche
dovetailed with a sideline of Louise's I
had another business a regular maid
service and I have to say that if you're
gonna be cleaning for a lemon this is
definitely more satisfying than being a
maid amid her heavy schedule with its
inherent sadness Louise tries to stay
upbeat the best part of my job is having
people say what a difference we made
people really have gratitude for what
you do they after they're in those
situations they realize what it would be
like a fan to do it and they're really
grateful